[Music]
do you remember deep down it was that
ps4 exclusive dungeon crawler that kind
of looked like Dark Souls but we haven't
really heard much about it in the past
couple of years
well Capcom recently submitted a
trademark application for it so it may
still be holding on for dear life
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
stay up to date on the status of
deep-down a trademark application for
deep-down was submitted on February 9th
and it's the second of its kind a
previous trademark from July 2013 is
still active and it's identical to the
most recent one what this means for the
game is unclear but it doesn't
necessarily spell a comeback for
Capcom's dungeon crawler deep down was
announced at the ps4 reveal event in
2013 but after some appearances at e3
and TGS in 2014 it mostly disappeared
Capcom reassured fans in 2015 that the
game wasn't cancelled but we haven't
heard anything since we'll keep you
up-to-date if anything comes to this but
for more medieval fighting right now why
not check out our let's play a for honor
where we crown GameSpot's greatest
office warrior
you